[music]
Today we're talking about RL
environments and how to scale them. But
the title is a little bit of a red
herring. We'll talk a bit about the
engineering pieces and like running
these with thousands of parallel
rollouts and sandboxes on hundreds of
GPUs, but I'm mostly going to focus on a
different notion of scale. Uh, and what
I mean by scaling here is we there's a
number of different ways we talk about
scaling in the context of AI and
research. We know about scaling laws and
we talk about how much data you need,
compute and parameters and that if you
pour in more data and compute and
parameters or inference time. All of
these things make models smarter or more
performant. But there's also fuzzier
side of scaling which is sometimes
referred to as unhobbling or algorithmic
tricks or talent. But where does this
come from? It's not just pouring in
resources, but it's something that is
more intangible, harder to put a finger
on, but really it comes from a community
of people, a company, an organization,
universities, the world, the internet,
talking about ideas and sharing them and
working on different applications,
having these applications inspire ideas,
using these ideas as test beds for
different techniques, and building on
top of these to increase the
accessibility for other people in the
future to not have to reinvent the wheel
and to be able to build from uh what has
been done by those before them to uh do
more effective research and accelerate
the pace of innovation.
And so why do we have this talent
bottleneck? There's a big issue that we
hear all about with AI labs trying to
like find more talent and salaries are
going through the roof and everyone
wants to hire the best and brightest AI
researchers. But one other approach
besides trying to just pay the most is
increase the pool. Uh and so how do we
increase the pool of AI researchers? How
do we make doing AI research more
accessible? And I want to talk a bit
about who we are at Prime Intellect. If
you haven't heard of us, we are a bunch
of things. We're a research lab. We are
a comput provider. We're a platform
company. And we are an open source
ecosystem. We do a lot of things and
they all fit together in a way that I'm
going to try to explain in this talk.
But we see these as all different pieces
of how we can build a business around
doing exactly this, which is increasing
the accessibility of AI research and
making doing research more of a toolkit
available to people at organizations
around the world without needing to be
inside of a large lab or without needing
to spend crazy amounts on massive
clusters or go do a PhD. We think that
there's versions of doing AI research
that really should be part of the
breadandbut workflows of AI engineers
around the world as we build
applications and try to improve our
systems and models and products.
And I think a thing people are kind of
iffy about in terms of AI is whether
open source models are going to work.
And in my mind, that's not quite the
right analogy to draw. And so when we're
comparing like AI to traditional
software, there's lots of like great
examples of open source software
ecosystems that have been thriving in
the past, things like Linux and Node and
Apache. But in my mind, the analogy in
AI is not models as kind of these fixed
checkpoints, but it's about research as
a practice and research as a set of
ideas. And it's one that's more
intangible, but there's a lot of
parallels in terms of the goals of the
best practices of growing a research
ecosystem as well as a software
ecosystem where you want to uh compound
abstractions and best practices and have
better tooling and iteration efficiency
and have these gains over time allow uh
more advanced powerful complex things to
be built by uh decreasing barriers to
entry for any given application and
allowing this to become more accessible.
And so one thing that we a term we'll
use to describe some of what we're
building at Prime Elect is we like this
phrase called the open super
intelligence stack. One because it's a
fun acronym but also I think the idea of
the stack of of all the pieces of the
puzzle to build the engine to go do
research. Uh there's a lot of layers to
it. You need compute uh you need
orchestration you need libraries for
doing uh training and evaluation and you
need platforms to support things like
code execution and eval inference and
fine-tuning and we're doing all these
things. Uh but really the goal of this
is to give people the tools to be able
to go train models. We want people more
people in the world. And we think I'll
explain why in a bit. There's a lot of
reasons why uh the best products are
going to be the ones that are not just
kind of taking the thing out of a box of
an API and putting a thin wrapper around
it. There's ways you can kind of improve
around APIs. But I think in many cases
people are realizing that winning
products are going to be the kinds of
things that whether it's a part of the
model, a part of the stack, the part of
the product or the whole thing, the
ability to do research and have at least
the option of deciding where in your
product you might want to customize a
model or improve a model gives you a lot
more flexibility to really u make the
best user experience. Um,
and so we have heard the phrase in the
past that the model is the product. And
I think we're starting to see now this
change a little bit to a lot of winning
applications have the product kind of be
the model. And I think the two notable
examples of this that I'm big fans of
and heavy users of are Cursor's new
composer model as well as uh OpenAI's
codeex. And I think these are both good
examples of models that really are where
the product kind of is the model very
directly where the the model was trained
to be the model for that product and the
experience of using the model is the
experience of using the product. And the
way that [clears throat] this is done is
by taking a harness that represents the
product and training the model in the
harness in essentially an environment,
an RL environment. And environments
really are just a harness with a
collection of tasks and rewards. But
they also have many other parallels
throughout the ecosystem. Environments
are not just for RL. Environments are
also essentially the same thing as
evals. Environments can also be engines
for synthetic data which then you can
use for SFT or distillation. You can do
RL in them directly. But also the agents
were actually deploying and monitoring
out in the world. These are
environments. The product of these
things, the tasks, the harness, and the
rewards, whether this is a data set
offline or the stream of user tasks
coming in to a product is an
environment. And so this as an
abstraction I think is a very useful way
of framing what it might look like to
start having uh research become more of
a a practice that is adopted more
broadly beyond just large AI labs. And I
also think that there's a sense in which
they're a really accessible entry point.
Uh and so I like the analogy of
environments as kind of like the web
apps of AI research. And what I mean by
this is that they're very simple.
They're self-contained. They can they
start simple but they can also get quite
complex. They can get very elaborate
representing the full complexity of a
large product. They're also pedagogical
in nature and that you can start simple
and as you build complexity, you start
bumping into these walls where you have
to start learning new concepts,
understanding more about scaling the
system side, understanding more about
the hyperparameters and the algorithms
and they kind of open this door where
you can by playing around with them
start entering into a world of research
without needing to kind of build a whole
training infrastructure system from
scratch. Um, and they also require
experimentation. And so I think the key
different uh differentiation between
just an agent harness and an agent
environment is that the environment
forces you to also have your tasks and
your rewards predefined to be able to do
this experimentation. It's a proper
eval. And what this means is that you
can't just vibe check it. You can't just
like build it and test it out a bit and
say, "Hey, it's good. We're going to
ship it." It forces you to say, "Okay,
let's think about this a little more
scientifically. Let's do some
experiments. lets try out different
models, try different hyperparameters.
Uh, and it also gets you to the point
where you can start doing more advanced
research in terms of RL training or
distillation or fine-tuning. And uh, so
to really facilitate this, we wanted to
make the environment as an entry point
much more accessible. A few months back,
we launched what we called the
environments hub, which is a open source
community platform for creating,
discovering, and sharing RL environments
and evals. And so far, we've had a lot
of fun kind of seeing everyone build
here. We've had hundreds of builders and
environments come create either their
own ideas or re-implement papers. Uh
there's a bunch of examples here I can
show you, but really it's just a bunch
of people who have wanted to do research
and found this as an entry point to
start digging a little deeper. Whether
this was investigating some benchmark
and figuring out how to reimplement it
or modify it to be appropriate for an RL
context in terms of like new data or new
examples or whether [snorts] this is
some game that they'd been thinking
about or some other task. But having
this as an abstraction for encapsulating
the the thing you want a model to do is
a way of allowing yourself to start
experimenting with ways of improving it
without needing to have the answers. So
I think people talk a lot about how
fine-tuning never really took off in the
SFT regime. And I think a big part of
this is that getting data was really
hard of the actual like solutions. I
think having labeled examples of what
you want the model to do is a very
difficult thing to ask someone to go
create. But if you can just think about
the the settings it might be in without
having the answers up front, if you can
measure the answers, now you kind of can
start creating data on the fly. And this
engine is really what the environment is
about unlocking. Um, and so actually 9
months ago, I was right here in this
room. I had just released a library
called verifiers, which I'm still
working on today. Um, it's come a long
way, but it's a toolkit for building
these things. And it's been a lot of fun
over this past year just playing with it
and extending it to support more
features and kinds of environments. But
the idea with verifiers is to give
people a toolkit that is uh essentially
a bunch of components that you can mix
and match and compose to do things like
from simple evals or QA or games to
things like tool use or using sandboxes
or agent frameworks or uh uh like CLI
coding agents or math problems. There's
all sorts of things you might want
models to do or agents to do. And it's a
toolkit for building environments that
is then uh ready to be automatically
trained with reinforcement learning. And
the way we thought about this design,
it's been a lot of fun and also a big
challenge to think like okay, how do you
make a toolkit for this stuff that
actually covers all the bases? And I
think there's a lot of different
approaches I've seen people go about and
I I think they all make sense depending
on what sorts of things you're wanting
to work on. But we took a very kind of a
general approach where we tried to say
we are not going to know all the answers
right away. There are going to be lots
of pattern. There's going to be lots of
special cases. There's going to be
hierarchies of complexity. There's going
to be patterns. And we really wanted to
prioritize extensibility. So we think
about these things hierarchically where
let's say you want to do a a coding
agent environment for client bench. uh
this which is an instance of the harbor
framework which is a example of a CLI
agent which is a multi-turn environment
which is an environment uh similar for
text arrina and Wordle or for search
with MCP or for giving a model a Python
ripple in a sandbox and so thinking of
these things hierarchically allows us to
kind of really determine like what are
the foundational pieces what is generic
across all environments and then how do
you build up the stack towards
applications
and so for one like example of this that
I'll kind of walk through the whole
process end to And we we call this one
wiki search, but it's basically a simple
search setting where we give an agent
the ability to uh call some tools to
search over Wikipedia pages and find
some answers. And so here is the
environments hub page. So the
environments hub is a kind of full stack
uh code management package registry. So
every environment is a Python project
where you can have dependencies and
versions and uploading your evals and
whatnot. Um but the environments are
very simple. They start simple. They can
get really complicated, but this one's
pretty simple where we just kind of
define our tools as async Python
functions. We have our data set and we
have what we call a rubric. And so a
rubric is the abstraction for managing
the different pieces of your rewards
where you can kind of compose different
things. You can also have metrics that
are just a zero award but are for in uh
observability of what's going on. And
then the other piece of doing training
will be a config. And so the config here
is for our prime RL trainer, which is
our kind of large scale training stack,
which has been our uh culmination of all
the best practices from the research
literature for large scale asynchronous
RL training. Um, but the config files
are intended to expose kind of the
pieces that people need to think about
in ways that are starting to get you
more into the algorithm, but are also
still designed to be pretty high level,
pretty self-contained, and with with
defaults that we think are going to be
sensible for a lot of people. And so
running this is just kind of running a
command line with uh you specify the
environment and if it's in the
environment hub it'll automatically
install it and start your training run
and then you can if you're lucky see
your reward curve just shoot right up.
Um and sometimes it doesn't go this
nicely but the process of doing this is
iterating on your environment on your
rewards and your data and your tasks to
understand what makes this task
holistically actually tangible in
practice. How do you tune the
parameters? How do you look at your
data? How do you define your rewards?
Uh, and if you do this right, you can
get really good improvements, especially
from really small models, but also for
much larger models. And so in this
example for the the wiki search one, we
started with a a Quen 3 4B model, which
was about 55%. And after training, it
was at 89% on par with uh much larger
models like GPT4.1 as well as reasoning
models like uh GBD5 mini. And so I think
this practice of taking small models and
being able to make them much better is a
big win for a lot of applications where
you either you want a really fast model,
you want a really cheap model, you want
a really really powerful model because
the best models out there just aren't
quite good enough. These are all the
different things you can do with model
customization. And this practice of
doing of creating environments isn't
only for customization, but it gives you
this option. And so if you need to do
eval anyways, it's useful to think of
them as environments because the
environment opens a lot of doors for
whether this is prompt tuning or whether
it's model selection or whether it's
just getting a better sense of how your
system could work at scale with many
many users in parallel. It's a design
process that really forces you to kind
of pin down what is the thing I care
about? What is my agent? What is my
product? What is my harness? What am I
optimizing for? Um, and so to kind of
fully stress test this, we've been
training a large model which will be out
into the world quite soon called
Intellect 3 with our full primal L
stack. And this has been us really kind
of validating the efficiency and
performance at a very large scale. So
this is a 100B plus model trained on 500
GPUs where we've kind of done the
endtoend uh post train of SFT and RL
which the primaril stack also has SFT if
people want to do that. But it's also
been about just understanding all the
best practices. We love reading papers
and we try to kind of try out all the
tricks and see which ones work and see
which ones don't and then distill this
into a library with Primaril that can
then be kind of consumed by the end user
without needing to do all this uh
implementation themselves. And so for us
it being open is very important. So
Primaril is on GitHub. You can go find
it. Verifiers is on GitHub if you want
to check it out. And for us, this is
really about opening the door for more
people to start learning about these
things and for incorporating it into
their workflows for optimizing their
models and their products. Um, and
[clears throat] the only way to do this
that we've what we see as the best way
to do this is through growing community.
And so for us, it's been really
important to really think about getting
good feedback loops from the people who
are building with this and understanding
what they want, understanding what's
going well, understanding what's
painful, and addressing those problems.
And so we've done a number of community
programs in terms of sponsoring
different kind of small tasks to uh a
research residency program with uh grad
students around the world uh and
collecting like uh a smaller subset of
the environment hub ones where we'll
actually review them manually. And so
this repo here, the prime environments
repo is the ones where we are doing
these directly where we're kind of
offering to look over someone's kind of
example. And so we've had hundreds of
these come in and there will be hundreds
more. And uh it's been a great learning
process because it's forced us to fix a
lot of things. We kind of understand the
rough edges. We understand what we need
to add. And we're kind of then
distilling [clears throat] all of these
learnings into what will be our kind of
upcoming uh platform product which we're
calling lab. And the idea of lab is to
give people an interface, a platform
where they can browse environments, they
can run their evals, they can do their
inference, they can do their fine-tuning
and they can have research be more
accessible in a way that it hasn't been
historically because I think a lot of
people find infrastructure very painful.
They find dealing with torch versions
painful, flash attention and VLM and
getting all these things to work. We are
happy to do that, but we understand that
a lot of people may not want to. Um, and
so the idea with this is that if you
want to go read the code, you can go
read the code, but you don't have to run
it. We can run it for you. Um, and so
this has been our version, which will be
kind of out into the world in the near
future of trying to allow people to
really focus on the environment where
the entry point to lab will be the
environment. If you want to do synthetic
data and SFT build, let's build an
environment. If you want to do your
evals, you build that as an environment.
If you want to do RL, you build an
environment. And I think building an
environment is the kind of thing that
I imagine a lot more people are going to
want to be doing as we start really
seeing where models are headed. In some
cases, this will be we're going to use
fine-tuning services from the labs
because they're going to offer this
because people want it. In some cases,
this will be we really care about the
smallest model we can run on prem at the
lowest latency and we're really just
going to optimize for our one thing. or
it could just be research for the sake
of research and advancing our kind of
collective understanding of how this
stuff all works. And I think that's
really our goal is to have a world where
there's going to be a lot of AI and
where we can all kind of talk about it
and understand it and look at it and
poke at it and tweak it and have a
better sense of what we're actually
building because I think there's a lot
of times when it feels like we're just
kind of the model is a black box and
digging into the research and going
under the hood and changing things and
breaking things tells you a lot about
how these models work. It tells you a
lot about understanding where they came
from, where they could be going, where
they might be headed, and preparing for
that future. Thanks.
[applause]
[music]